[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que nos invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas los muertos en
Turquía y Siria se cuentan por decenas
de miles tras los devastadores
terremotos del 6 de febrero una cifra
que podría aumentar dramáticamente pues
el lunes Naciones Unidas informó que las
labores de búsqueda y rescate están
llegando a su fin esto para concentrar
esfuerzos en los sobrevivientes una
semana después se estima que podrían ser
miles de las personas a un sepultadas y
los rescatistas tuvieron éxito en sacar
a unas cuantas personas más dentro de
los escombros un equipo de France 24
estuvo allí presenciando uno de estos
salvamentos que muchos han tildado de
milagros
verde
aquí en Antioquia más de 130 horas
después del terremoto
cuando los rescatistas corren significa
una cosa Hay una oportunidad de vida
bajo los escombros un bebé ha sido
encontrado
no tarda en llegar la noticia a las
familias de los que vivían aquí
[Música]
tras horas bajo tierra emergen los
rescatistas cubiertos de polvo han
intentado extraer a una familia de cinco
personas atrapada en el segundo piso
tiene un video grabado hace unos minutos
para esta afligida tía llega la
confirmación por fin de que su sobrina
llamada ligue de un año se ha salvado
[Música]
tras una agónica espera en silencio por
el momento no se detecta nadie más
los tíos de aliye se dirigen al hospital
en helicóptero la búsqueda continúa
hasta tarde solo interrumpida brevemente
por una réplica
Pero al final llega la confirmación los
familiares directos de aliye no
sobrevivieron
es un bebé milagro una sobreviviente de
uno de los momentos más oscuros de
Turquía
en Turquía en la localidad de bello Club
los habitantes se convirtieron en
rescatistas ante la falta de apoyo
Estatal mientras que en el cementerio
del vecino chequera Las lápidas nuevas
ya superan a las que existían antes de
la catástrofe el siguiente es un informe
de nuestros enviados especiales Adrián
rocha y bernaya
en el pequeño pueblo de beyolo 10.000
habitantes todos se conocen todos saben
quién viven qué casa Quién es familia de
quién y desde el terremoto del lunes
quien ha muerto y quién
Asís un vecino del lugar cree que el
número de fallecidos se acerca a los 300
lo sabe también porque él rescató
algunos de sus vecinos aquí no ha venido
ningún Equipo de rescate
yo saqué a dos personas les había caído
su edificio encima y solo los
conseguimos sacar después de que
fallecieran yo no saqué a nadie con vida
pero otros vecinos sí que consiguieron
hacerlo aquí y en otros pueblos todos
intentaron hacerlos con sus propios
recursos la ayuda sin embargo sí que ha
llegado pero tarde los vecinos del lugar
han recibido comida y agua pero
necesitan Con urgencia productos
sanitarios pero sobre todo tiendas de
campaña la mayoría de los habitantes de
bellow duerme a la intemperie
congelándose a varios grados bajo cero
esta familia por suerte tenía en su casa
plásticos y telas halil el padre
consiguió de todo ello crear un lugar
donde dormir en su propio jardín
unos kilómetros más al sur el pueblo de
chequerova y su cementerio Las lápidas
nuevas las frescas las improvisadas
superan a las antiguas hussein cuya casa
queda cerca intenta ayudar a las
familias que lloran a sus seres queridos
las familias como pueden traen sus
fallecidos el cementerio ellos mismos
los entierran esta noche ha habido dos
entierros en uno de ellos había tres
fallecidos eran una madre y sus dos
hijos que fueron encontrados muertos
mientras estaban abrazados sus cuerpos
estaban Unidos había mucho olor
muchos según Justin Ese es el primer día
desde el terremoto que el cementerio
está tranquilo Las lápidas no todas
tienen marcados algunos nombres tuba
kadir zeynep sus apellidos sus historias
son desconocidas
para el mundo serán un número que se
sumará a otras decenas de miles para sus
familias un punto y final
cuando faltan pocos días para que se
cumpla un año de la guerra Rusia sigue
reclamando victorias en la región de
lombas los combates se concentran en
torno a la localidad de bakmuth donde
las tropas ucranianas exhaustas se ven
obligadas a refugiarse en sótanos
secretos para descansar en momentos en
los que Rusia ejerce presión por
quedarse con el control de esta zona del
país que Ucrania no está dispuesta a
ceder la otan hace un llamado para
acelerar la entrega de armamento
municiones y combustible a quiebre
veamos el siguiente informe de nuestra
cadena aliada
Solo queda un camino que permite entrar
y salir de la ciudad por el momento lo
utilizan principalmente vehículos
blindados y ambulancias ucranianas pero
es una ruta que los rusos están tratando
de acortar en el terreno las tropas
ucranianas son pesimistas sobre la
situación
la situación es muy difícil para
nosotros los rusos están cercando vacmut
para descansar los soldados se refugian
bajo tierra en este sótano de la ciudad
las tropas rotan entre el campo de
batalla y la seguridad es un espacio
pequeño para los cientos de hombres que
este alberga sus rostros están marcados
por el agotamiento y la ansiedad algunos
están durmiendo mientras otros están
preparando su salida de regreso al
frente de batalla
los rusos son tan numerosos que parecen
hormigas que avanzan mientras nos
empujan hacia atrás Es difícil mantener
vivos a nuestros soldados y aguantar
psicológicamente
el equipo médico evacuar los soldados
heridos y muertos todos los días un
trabajo que pasa factura
ayudar a los soldados heridos es lo más
difícil psicológicamente pero lo peor es
cuando ya no estás en el frente cuando
estás aquí y tienes tiempo para
reflexionar es un infierno
los soldados descansan durante 24 horas
antes de regresar al combate las fuerzas
ucranianas se enfrentan al fuego ruso
desde múltiples lados a medida que sus
tropas avanzan desde el norte el sur y
el este estas imágenes filmadas en las
calles de bakmuth muestran que la ciudad
ahora es una zona de guerra pero a pesar
de la creciente presión rusa Ucrania no
tiene planes de entregar bakmut sin
luchar
los estadounidenses sufren por el
incremento en el precio del huevo un
ingrediente básico en sus cocinas varios
factores han contribuido a esta
situación por un lado está en la Guerra
de Ucrania que ha provocado Un aumento
en los precios de los granos con los
cuales se alimentan a las gallinas que
por el otro un grave caso de gripe aviar
que ha acabado con por lo menos 50
millones de aves en el país la situación
están que ahora las autoridades
fronterizas luchan por frenar el tráfico
de huevos desde México el reporte lo
trae desde Nueva York nuestra
corresponsal
en esta enorme nevera Rafael guarda la
comida de cuatro refugios sociales no
solo tenemos que alimentar a la gente
que está aquí tenemos más que alimentar
tienen de casi todo pero le preocupa la
falta de un alimento fundamental los
huevos
ayer teníamos que haber recibido 180.000
pero solo recibimos 120
de uno de nuestros donantes en
Pensilvania
Si antes una docena de huevos costaba
alrededor de 4 dólares ahora supera los
9 y eso ha provocado que disminuyan las
donaciones por eso hoy se distribuirán
menos en el resto de los centros que
dependen de este refugio
Si ves huevos cocidos el martes y
hacemos huevos revueltos el domingo
solíamos cocinar huevos tres veces a la
semana pero ahora hemos tenido que
recortar porque tenemos que asegurarnos
que todos nuestros centros tienen huevos
estoy haciendo avena con banano Rafael
compensa la falta de proteína del huevo
con otros Alimentos como la crema de
maní o la tocineta opciones menos sanas
pero más económicas los huevos se han
convertido en mercancía de contrabando
con México desde California hasta Texas
los agentes fronterizos han tenido al
menos 2.000 encuentros en el último mes
con personas que trataban de introducir
este alimento en los Estados Unidos y
todo porque allí en México es más barato
una caja de 30 huevos cuesta solo 3
dólares y medio Los Altos precios
también afectan a restaurantes como el
de Benjamin por mucho tiempo no teníamos
y tuve que conducir a diferentes lugares
de long island upstate Nueva York sólo
por encontrar huevos según el
departamento de agricultura en el 2022
cada persona consumió una media de 278
huevos
uno diario
es alimento estrella de los
estadounidenses y muchos locales El
sándwich
Así que ha sido duro la peor parte se la
llevan los más desfavorecidos las
alternativas al huevo no siempre cubren
Todas las necesidades y según los
expertos pueden pasar varios meses hasta
que los precios de este alimento vuelvan
a estabilizarse
queremos agradecer
por prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
realización de este programa y a ustedes
también Muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana Así que con
más información